hello hello I am back and I'm here to
make a very exciting announcement I have
officially enjoyed some things
throughout the month of January and I'm
gonna tell you what those things were
whoa
also I'm writing a book but we'll get to
that later podcast I recently asked you
guys on Twitter for suggestions for
podcasts to listen to and one that
popped up quite a lot was call your
girlfriend I realized recently that the
majority of the podcast I listen to are
made by white dudes and it kind of hmm
didn't make me feel very good and so
although cool your girlfriend doesn't
feel like it is made for me I am
thoroughly enjoying it and finding it
very helpful actually as a straight
white male I have found it incredibly
valuable to be able to listen to
conversations the women have when I am
not there I would recommend it to
anybody because it's just you know
genuinely very funny and informative but
specifically I would recommend it to
straight white dudes who want to shed a
bit of ignorance ergo this guy yeah it's
great go listen to it
Vinci game I honestly can't remember
where I found out about this game but
it's undertale and it is just brilliant
if you're a fan of the old role-playing
game if you played a bit of Pokemon in
your time this is perfect kind of like
deconstruction of those type of games it
is quite an ugly looking game but I do
think that is deliberate and is kind of
part of the charm of it I'll spoil one
thing for you just one moment in the
game that was particularly brilliant in
my mind there's a point where you're
battling to Royal Guards and there are
two ways to complete the battle either
you can kill them or you can convince
garden number two to take his top off
and then encourage guard number one to
admit his feelings to guard number two
and the battle ends when they go and
have ice cream together simultaneously
incredibly hilarious and weirdly
heartwarming and that's kind of what
this game is it's much more than you
would expect it to be I would thoroughly
recommend it experience oh this is
actually something I did back in October
but you know what I haven't been up to
much recently and it was really good so
I'm just gonna talk about anyway the
cosmonauts exhibition at the Science
Museum holy poop it is so good the main
thing I learned from it was how madly
indoctrinated I've been into thinking
that the most important part of the
space race was Americans landing on the
moon
because the Russians did quite a lot
more than just that whether they do
first satellite first man in space first
woman in space first space walk a fair
amount of the stuff they have there is
replicas but there is some things in
there that actually have been in space
it's kind of incredible I was really
fortunate to experience this exhibition
in private on my birthday with my
friends so I have some input inherent
bias towards it but it was just
brilliant it's just so good and if
you're in London and you can go to the
Science Museum please do cosmonauts
people cosmonauts cosmonauts don't know
why I'm thinking that this will
encourage you clothes models ah now I
want to go application I'm not gonna
spend too much time on this but face
what live any application that lets you
do this is just my favorite thing in the
world what does the Teletubby baby son
do just sort of laughs doesn't it I also
really love this just this is me as the
Queen that's just me as the Queen why is
that why does the Queen fit so well on
my face I don't know that doesn't work
quite as well does it it's making me
happy though YouTube video easily the
standout video for me that I watched on
YouTube this month was from Julia Nunes
if the video for her song make out if
you like me you're probably the kind of
person who gets really uncomfortable
when you see people kissing on camera
and maybe it's the fact that this video
incorporates a lot of real couples I
think it's real couples anyway I I was
convinced if it isn't but this music
video just made me really happy just
felt like a very positive thing go and
watch it go watch people make out it's
great also make out yourself if you have
the opportunity and if you'd like to I
would recommend that to one of my
January favorites that's it
please do let me know some of the things
you enjoyed last month as well because
you know last time I asked that I found
the new favorite podcast so I'm not
being facetious I actually do what your
recommendations and I'll see you in the
next one of these good bye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool thank you very much
for watching I am gonna direct you to
the trailer for undertale assuming there
is one I actually don't know but you
should just really play their game as
well as Julia Nunes this video may count
so those are both there for your
convenience thanks for coming back as
well SOI see you
flea the fact that I am writing a book
is some explanation as to why I've been
away recently but I think it's gonna be
really good and I'm sorry I have to be
vague but I'm not allowed to say
anything more just yet that's it nothing
else that's the whole thing it's cold oh
dear